A nadie se le escapa que esta ley
es 1 refuerzo para la legislatura.
Esta ley encarrila la legislatura
y esta es 1 legislatura que nació asediada
desde que se invistió
al gobierno de coalición de izquierdas,
hubo poderes muy destacados
que respondieron a 1 llamamiento,
ese llamamiento que hizo el señor José María Aznar
que dijo, quien pueda hacer, que haga, que puede interver,
intervenir, que intervenga.
Desde que pasó eso
hubo 1 verdadera ofensiva reaccionaria
contra el gobierno,
de la cual los fascistas en Ferraz eran solo
la infantería,
pero importantes estamentos del poder económico,
del poder, del estado,
Han llevado
todo este tiempo 1 estrategia de asedio contra
el gobierno, simple y llanamente
porque no le gustaba el gobierno salido
de la representación popular.
Bueno, la legislatura hoy sale reforzada
y eso significa que encarrilamos el camino para hacer
aquellas cosas por las que no votaron